c'est étonnant non
[Musique]
ce soit exceptionnellement en hommage à
l'inventeur de l'espéranto le docteur
brochard dont nous fêtons aujourd'hui le
centenaire de la naissance de la soeur
nous allons observer ensemble une
seconde de silence
merci avant l'invention de l'espéranto
le barrage de la langue constitue est
une inépuisable source de discorde entre
les hommes rappelez vous
puis je vous demander du feu s'il vous
plaît fais une kodela talent dès
aujourd'hui grâce à l'espéranto
nous pouvons en jambes et avec
allégresse les infranchissable
frontières du langage regardez bien puis
je vous demande à du feu dit s'il vous
plaît désolât jeu permet d'allumer dit
qu'on se moque et tonino et tonine
étonnant non
[Musique]
fait étonnant non